my parents constantly asked me to clear
their clutter for them but they aren't
willing to give up anything what do I do
well so my pithy answer to this and
maybe we could talk a little bit about
it is doing is often the opposite of
helping well think about this for a
second I mean yeah you could help them
by maybe doing it together right but if
I'm constantly doing something for you
I'm not really helping you unless you
absolutely need to help right right if
you broke both of your legs and both of
your arms I'm happy to get you food
while you recover but it's like after
you've recovered I'm still spoon feeding
you like that's not helping anyone
rights analyzing them so I think what is
happening right now is is Taylor is
infantilizing his or her parents I'm not
sure if Taylor's a guy or gal here but
but you might just be infantilizing you
in fact enabling them and keeping them
from growing if they're asking for help
then maybe the best way to help them is
to show them how you do it together yeah
my short answer is this helping is
helpful unless the people you're helping
don't want help mmm and ultimately I
think about I had a situation with a
family member where they were doing a
lot of drugs and another family member
was like hey I need you to talk to
so-and-so they're having a really hard
time they're hooked on drugs and it
would really mean a lot to me if you
went and tried to help him out and I
went and talked to this family member
and from the first sentence that they
said like I could tell they didn't want
help like they knew they had a problem
but they were okay with having a problem
yeah and that's the only conversation I
had with them about trying to help them
essentially because all because
ultimately trying to help them when they
don't want help was driving me it would
drive me mad it drove me mad growing up
my mother was a really bad alcoholic
most of most of my childhood years and
you know as a kid you don't really
understand why and you're like hey if
you loved me you would stop ray and I
would try to help and I thought it was
helpful to like hide her wine or hide
her beer that was I mean it it
temporarily stopped the problem I saw
hilarious video on on Jesus and maro
they were yeah that they go over like
clips there was this kid who's trying to
goes mom to stop smoke and he was a
constantly sneak up on her with a pair
of scissors and just cut the tip off of
her cigarette and run away she'd get mad
and throw his stuff out in the same
thing we're kind of having my mom except
there was no hilarity ensuing like I
didn't have anything front like I was
just like really hurt by the whole whole
thing and realized like she sometimes
she wanted help but there were times
when she didn't and I was like I was
trying to force help on the sub one you
can't drag someone kicking and screaming
to success no I mean there's always an
exception to the rule but that's not
that's not a good plan right yeah yeah
and so I think it sounds to me like
there here's the good good news though
they're asking you for help it sounds
like they're asked you to clear that
maybe they're not maybe they're saying
oh we're lazy even want you to clean all
of our clutter now that's the case then
you say I can't help you but if they're
saying hey can you help me say yeah I'd
be happy to help you let's the three of
us get together this Saturday at 2 p.m.
and I'll show you exactly how I'm able
to organize my stuff and I think it'll
help you out a lot
so be willing to help if they want the
help but only if they're willing to help
you know the other selves the other
thing too like I just thought with you
saying that is his parents have to
contribute somehow right hey get rid of
my stuff and then I put the burden on
you to get rid of my stuff Josh you come
over to my house and then I just push
back on everything you try to help me
with so Taylor don't don't keep spinning
your wheels here won't even words to
help in a drowning person you might
drown yourself yeah yeah tweet that Sean
you